[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه الكرام لماذا يتمنى الكثير من
العربي
ممثلا امريكا واوروبا ماذا يمكن ان
يقدمهم كادوات في الحرب
للغزو الروسيه لاوكرانيا هل يا ترى
الاحتلال الروسي لاوكرانيا حلال والاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لفلسطين حرام لماذا يتناسون ان
روسيا كامريكا قتلت وشردت ملايين المسلمين
في افغانستان وسوريا والشيشان وليبيا
وغيرها لماذا يتناسى العرب ان روسيا كانت
اول بلد في العالم يعترف باسرائيل هل
يعلمون ايضا ان بعض الطيارين الاسرائيليين
الذين يقصفون غزه وسوريا من اصول الروسيه
لكن في المقابل اليست الاضرار التي
الحقتها روسيا بالعربي والمسلمين اقل
بكثير من الاضرار التي الحقتها امريكا
والغرب الا يكفي ان الروس انسحبوا من
اتفاق سايكس بيكو الذي قسم العالم العربي
بعد ان كانوا شركائها مع البريطانيين
والفرنسيين فيه هل فعلا ان روسيا غزت
سوريا ام انها دفعت عنها ضد الارهاب
والمشاريع الغربيه لم تبدا بعض الدول
العربيه تبتعد اصلا عن القوه الغربيه
وتتقرب من الروس كما حصل في اجتماع منظمه
اوبك بلس الاخير الا تبدو روسيا اكثر
احتراما لشركائها العرب من امريكا مثلا
اسئله اطرحها عبر الاقمار الصناعيه من
موسكو على الدكتور محمود الافندي المستشار
لدى وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه وعبر الاقمار
الصناعيه من فينا على الكاتب والمحلل ثائر
الناشف نبدا نقاش بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره ثانيه
هل تستطيع ان تنكر انه في الصراع الدائري
الان بين روسيا والغرب
هناك قسم من العرب من الشارع العربي وقسم
كبير لا يستهان به من الانظمه العربيه
بدات تميل باتجاه روسيا بعيدا عن الغرب
هل تعتقد ان هذا التوجه العربي شعبيا
وسياسيا في محله بخصوص الميلان باتجاه
روسيا
مساء الخير دكتور استاذ المشاهدين لا
اعتقد ان التعويل والرهان على روسيا يمكن
ان يقدم اي شيئا للعرب خاصه وان روسيا
ارتكبت مجازر يندى لها الجبين خلال
السنوات الماضيه في سوريا وحدها ارتكبت
حتى الان اكثر من
6943 مجزره قضى منها اكثر من 2040 طفل
و977 امراه اكثر من 1243 اعتداء على
المنشات المدنيه فضلا عن حربها العشوائيه
العباسيه على اوكرانيا استخدمت روسيا في
سوريا وحدها اكثر من 200 و37 غاره
بالقنابل العنقوديه فضلا عن استخدامها
لاكثر من 130 غار بالقنابل الحارقه فضلا
عن استخدامها لاكثر من 320 نوع من الاسلحه
الجديده التي اعلن عنها وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجي شويه انه استخدم احدث
الاسلحه الروسيه في سوريا قبل طرحها في
الاسواق بمعنى ان روسيا اليوم تستخدم
الشعوب لتدمر امكانياتها وقدراتها
وبالتالي روسيا لا يمكن التعويل عليها
مطلقا في ما يخص القضايا العربيه او ان
تكون قطبا موازيا للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه روسيا اليوم ترتكب مجازر في
اوكرانيا كما حدث في بلده بوتجا لا تقل
هذه المجزره عن المجازر التي ارتكبتها في
سوريا في سوريا وحدها اكثر من 60 غاره
ارتكبتها روسيا في اسواق شعبيه واكثر من
230 مدرسه سوريه تعرضت للهدم من الطيران
الحربي الروسي فضلا عن اكثر من 360 مجزره
من ضمن المجازر التي خاضتها روسيا منذ عام
2015 يعني روسيا اليوم مسؤوله عن اكثر من
اربعه واربع ملايين ونصف لاجئ سوري قبل ان
تتدخل سوء روسيا في سوريا لم يكن هناك
لاجئون سوريون في اوروبا لكن منذ ان تدخلت
روسيا طيب الى سوريه
للشعب السوري روسيا مسؤوله عن هذه الاعداد
الهائله طبعا
بالجو العامي يعني بالمجمل العام طيب كيف
يعني باختصار لكن رغم كل هذا الكلام لا
يمكن ان تنكر بان الشارعين العربي الشارع
العادي والشارع السياسي او الرسمي اذا صح
التعبير هناك توجه باتجاه روسيا وهناك
تحول تحول لصالح روسيا جاوبني هل يمكن
للمراهنه على روسيا في القضايا العربيه
بجمله كي اذهب لمحمود
روسيا لا يمكن ان تحقق التوازن في
المعادلات الدوليه ولا يمكن ان تصبح قطبا
دوليا اما فيما يتعلق بمشاعر الشارع
العربي روسيا تتلاعب بهذه المشاعر لانها
تعلم ان الشارع العربي ممتلئ بالاحباط من
السياسات الغربيه وهذا لا يخفى على احد
وبالتالي روسيا تحاول ان تدغدغ مشاعر
الجماهير العربيه من خلال اعلانها انها
تقف الى صالح القضايا العربيه لكن روسيا
اليوم هي من اكبر الدول المنحاذه لاسرائيل
وهي من اكبر الدول التي تدير ظهرها للعرب
اثر كل ازمه يقع بها العرب او يجد بها
العرب انفسهم منذ ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي
وحتى الان روسيا لا تمتلك المقومات
الكامله لكي تكون دوله يمكن التعويل
والرهان عليها لا روسيا ولا الصيد
وبالتالي اليوم روسيا لا يمكن ان تصبح همم
يعني ان يكون لها الدور طيب بالحقيقه
يكافئ او يوازي دور الغرب او حتى دور
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والعرب يتركون
ذلك جيدا لكن حاله الاحباط الشعبي وحاله
الانفعال السلبي والاحتجاج الذي يعبر عنه
الجماهير العربيه حقيقه لا يعكس معظم
التطلعات العربيه ولا حتى المشاعر العربيه
الكامله فيما يتعلق بالانحياز الى روسيا
على حساب غيرها ثم ان روسيا اليوم هزمت في
اوكرانيا
عن اي رهان على على نعم جميل جدا محمود
الافندي كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
اول شيء يسعد مساك دكتور فيصل الاخوه
المشاهدين طبعا روسيا بتاريخ 24/02 بتاريخ
24 شباط سن الماضيه اشعلت فتيل الثوره في
العالم فتيل الثوره للاستقلال والخروج لكل
دول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لتاخذ
سيادتها واستقلالها ان كان الاقتصادي
والسياسي والاجتماعي هذا امر مهم جدا لان
كل دول العالميه مسلوبه السياده
مسلوبه السياده بشكل كامل تحت هيماته
المتحده الامريكيه هذا امر مهم جدا لذلك
نرى ان فعليا هذه الثوره نجحت روسيا في
شكل فعلي جدا وخصوصا في البلدان العربيه
عندما قررت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
بدايه المعركه العسكريه ان تدمر اقتصاد
الروسي بشكل ضرب قاضيه لم تستطيع بسبب
ماذا بسبب ان فعليا هذه الدول ومنها الدول
العربيه لم تطبق العقوبات على الروسيا
ففعليا لم تسمر عقوبات الى اي شيء لذلك
الاقتصاد الروسي لم ينهار كما تريد
ففعليا الدول العربيه ودول العالم الاخر
هي الشريكه فيما يسمى الثوره الان
الموجوده على الهيمنه الامريكيه لماذا
يعني فعليا اذا رجعنا التاريخ شويه انا
امبارح اعلق على كلام السيد سائر لانه كله
خارج عن الواقع وكله اتهامات بلا اي ادله
ولا اي دليل في اتهاماته اذا انفعليا
النظرنا انه الان الدول العربيه تعيد
تستعيد سيادتها لتصبح دول قويه روسيا تهدي
الان العالم ثوره للتخلص من العين
الامريكيه هذا يعطيها سيادتها لانه الدوله
سياده وهي مستعمره او اتحد ايمن دوله اخرى
لا تستطيع ان تصبح دوله كبيره او تصبح
دوله اقتصاديه او تقدر ان تدافع عن نفسها
وتصبح دوله
روسيا تقدم على الطبق بالذهب الان هذه
السياده لكل هذه الدول فعليا الان درجه
كيف تتراجع سيادتك تاخذ سيادتها بس دقيقه
سيد محمود سيد محمود يعني بيربع بيربح هل
يعني بيربي مصدق هذا الكلام اللي عم تحكي
انت مصدق هذا الكلام يا زلمه روسيا بدها
تقدم سياده للعرب هل تقدم لنا السياده هل
روسيا تقدم لنا السياده وهي تدمر جارتها
وابناء جلدتها الاوكرانيين على حدودها يا
زلمه مجنون يحكي وعاقل يسمع قال شو قال
روسيا بدها تعطينا سيادي يا رجل ماذا تركت
لنا في سوريا ماذا تركت لنا في سوريا يعني
في كلام معقول يا زلمه
انا بحكي لك كلام معقول لانه اول شيء
بالنسبه الاوكراني هذا امر مهم جدا
اوكرانيا اوكرانيا اول شيء اميريكا قامت
بانقلاب عام 2014 واتت في القوميه
الاوكرانيين المدعوين الغرب والسيطره على
الحكومه وفعليا انشاوا من القران
تستطيع ان تقدم عدد
الاقتصاديه لهذه الدول الفعليه كل الدول
التاريخ فعليا من دمر الاتحاد السوفيتي هي
السعوديه عندما تزيل اسعار النفط ولكن
اختر هذا الامور عام 2016 روسي اسست ما
يسمى مجموعه اوبيروس وشرحت لكل الدول
العربيه عندما تكون اقتصاديين اقوياء
ستزدهر بلادكم وتصلون على زياده وتقويه
الجيش قوي واسلحه قويه فعليا فعليا الان
بدا يحصل نرى ان السعوديه بدات تتخذ
سيادتها ووقفت وهمم يعني ضربت بكل الحائط
بقناه المتحده الامريكيه بزياده النفط لك
حتى وزير الطاقه القطريه البارحه اولت
البارحه رفض ان يبول وورد غاز الى اوروبا
اذا حددوا اسعار الغاز الروسي هذا كله دول
تريد الان تصبح
سياده عن طريق الاقتصاد لانه الدوله هي
دوله اهم شيء الاق اذا كان الاقتصاد قوي
ومستقل تستطيع هذه الدوله ان تكن لها
سياده سياسيه
واجتماعيه فعليا هذا ما يحصل مع الدول
العربيه الان اما ان نقول ان سوريا ادى
روسيا تعتدي روسيا تعتذر لاحد ولا بطريقا
روسيا لما اتت الى اوكرانيا اتت لي توقيف
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لان وصلت على
حدودها لانه ليس هناك شعب اوكراني بانه
هناك فقط همم
الجيش اوكراني مدعوم امريكيه عندما دخلت
يعني بطريقه شرعيه لحمايه سوريه لانه
سوريه كانت راح تنهار
حمامات سلبي
جميل جدا
روسيا حمامه سلام يجب ان يصفق لها العرب
نعم
يعني حقيقه روسيا لا تحترم حلفائها في
المنطقه مطلقا اذا ما اجرينا مقارنات فقط
بين الدول التي ترتهن لصالح روسيا في
اوروبا الشرقيه مقارنه بالدول الحديثه
للمتحده للولايات احد الامريكيه ونظرنا
كيف ان الدول في اوروبا الشرقيه تعاني
اليوم من الفساد والمافيا وتعاني من الفقر
وتعاني من البطاله مقارنه بالدول الحليفه
للولايات احد الامريكيه والتي كانت في ما
مضى تحت الجناح السوفيتي ومنها دوله مثل
فيتنام اليوم اصبحت من الدول المتطوره
بلدان الخليج العربي يتحدث عن ان الولايات
ان ان البلدان الخليجي اليوم اصبح حتى
تمتع بسياسه همم مختلفه تماما عن السياسه
السابقه وهذا من يعني ميزات التحدث مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وانا لست هنا
بصدد الدفاع عن الولايات احد الامريكيه
لكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تتيح
لحلفائها ان ينوعوا في علاقاتهم وان كانت
هناك علاقات عربيه روسيه او علاقات خليجيه
روسيه فهذا نوع من التنويع وليس نوع من
بناء التحالفات روسيا لا تسمح لحلفائها ثم
ان روسيا ليس لديها حلفاء بالمناسبه
بالمنطقه روسيا لديها اذناب وديول وراينا
كيف انها اذلت ذنبها في سوريا بشار الاسد
عندما زار بوتين قاعده حميميم الجويه كيف
صوره الذل والمهانه التي ظهر بها ها هم
حلفاء روسيا مذلون مهاونون راينا كيف ان
وزير الدفاع الروسي وبوتين ايضا اهان وزير
الدفاع السوري عندما زاروا المسجد الاموي
في دمشق هذا لم يحصل معه وزراء دفاع
امريكيون او مع وزاره الدفاع امريكيين او
مع وزراء خارجيه
امريكيين العقليه الامريكيه اذا صنفت انها
عقليه استعماريه فهي عقليه منفتحه مقارنه
مع العقليه الروسيه المنغلقه التي تنتمي
حقيقه للعقليه للستالينيه والعقليه
القيصريه لا تنفك عن هاتين العقليتين التي
مضى عليهما الزمن فروسيا اليوم تريد ان
للشعوب وتقهرها باسم العلاقات والتحالفات
وما يسمى بالعداله التي طرحها الضيف الاخر
لكن روسيا حقيقه لم تشذ مترا واحدا او
سنتيمترا واحدا عن العقليه السلينيه
والعقليه القيصريه التي تقوم على استعمار
واستدلال الشعوب روسيا كمستعمر لا يترك
شيئا للشعوب التي يستعملها راينا في سوريا
كيف انهم نهبوا الخيرات ولا يزالوني
يذهبونها اكثر من 80 شركه استثماريه روسيه
في سوريا
وتذهب خيرات الشعب السوري بحجه ان روسيا
تريد تسديد خيرات ثروات نفطيه حقول النفط
من الاشياء اتفاقنار التي تحمي حقول النفط
الثوره وحق القاره
طردتهم ايران
من دير الزور فقط لتستوي روسيا يعني
خلفائكم الايرانيين لم يستطيعوا ان ياخذوا
يعني برميل نفطر واحد من نصف دير الزور
اليوم روسيا تستولي بالكامل على النفط
السوري في شرق الفرات وكذلك ايضا على
الغاز والفوسفات الذي تعتبر سوريا واحده
من خمسه دول مصدره للفوسفات بالعالم عدا
عن الاستثمارات الروسيه ما يسمى
دوله
لا تنتمي يعني دوله بالنسبه للعقود التي
ابرمتها روسيا هي عقود النهر حقيقه هذه
عقود تسقط تعتبر روسيا نفسها انها سوف
تحافظ على هذه العقود فيما لو تغير نظام
الاسد ولذلك تصادق على هذه العقود مع مجلس
الشعب وليس مع دوله بشار الاسد وتحصرها
برجالات بنظام الاسد ولكن بموجب اتفاقيه
في ان تعتبر هذه الاتفاقات باطله لانها
تنتهي قواعد القانون الدولي طالما ان نظام
الاسد لا يملك السياده الكامله السوريه في
سوريا لا يستطيع النظام ان يتحكم به تسقط
اي اتفاقيه دوليه فبالتالي على ماذا روسيا
تراهن او على من يراهنون على روسيا يعني
هناك اسئله كثيره جدا ان تطرح
ليعرف كيف ان كيف تفكر روسيا وكيف ل- جميل
جدا محمود الافندي محمود الافندي
خلينا بنبسط الموضوع للمشاهد روسيا ماذا
يمكن برجع بسالك سؤال ماذا يمكن ان تقدم
لنا على ضوء ما شاهدناها انا بدي اسالك
سؤال بالله ماذا قدمت روسيا كي لا نبتعد
كثيرا مشان يعني عندنا امثله محدده للذين
يراهنون على روسيا ويصفقون لروسيا ويامرون
خيرا ويحلمون بانها ستغير الواقع العالمي
والى هناك هنالك ماذا قدمت انت سوري ماذا
قدمت للسوريين على المستوى الاقتصادي
السوريون نسبه الفقر في سوريا نسبه الفقر
في سوريا اكثر من 92% 93% لا قمح لا خبز
لا غاز لا كذا وانت تعلم ان روسيا من اكبر
يعني تمتلك اكبر الثروات الغازيه والنفطيه
في العالم ماذا قدمت للسوريين على العكس
تماما
روسيا حيث ما حلت تبدا بانهاب اكثر من
الغربيين بالف مره وقال لها قبل ايام كان
رئيس مخابرات السوريه في السويداء سالوه
اين المازوت اين البنزين هذا لوقا اسمه ما
بعرف شو اه قل البنزين والمازوت وكل
مشتقات الطاقه ذهبت لحلفائنا الروس
والايرانيين ومسجل ومسجل هذا كلامه يا سيد
محمود ماذا كم كم لا شيء بس دقيقه كم لاجئ
عربي استقبلت روسيا ولا لا ليسوا مستعدين
ان ينفقوا دولارا واحدا قال لي هذا الكلام
مسؤول روسي الغرب استقبل ملايين اللاجئين
العرب ملايين اللاجئين العرب يا عرب
انظروا كم استقبل للغرب وكم استقبل روسيا
روسيا تريد النائب والسلب والقتل لا اكثر
ولا اقل كيف ترد عليها
اول شيء يعني اهم شيء اهم شيء اللي قلته
دكتور فيصل ماذا تقدم ولماذا تقدم روسيا
اول الشيء روسيا لا تنهب بالنسبه لسوريا
كل الكلام اللي حكاه استاذ السعر وانت
والدكتور فيصل الي حكيته غير منطقي لان
ليس هناك بسوريا ما يصلح الموجود كل
السنوات الاقتصاديه او الثروات مع
الموجوده بسوريا هي موجوده في الجزء
الشمال الشرقي في سوريا يعني هو تحت سيطره
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليس بكل سوريه
من ان كان قمحا وان كان اسمه كان الشمال
الشرقي اسمه خزان سوريا الاقتصادي فمن
يسيطر على هذه المنطقه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وليست روسيا يعني لسه هناك ما
يسرى الذي يسرق هو الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بالعكس سوريا تقدمت من حتى من
سن حتى الان قدمت ثلاث
حوالي ثلاثه مليون ثوم قبل احمد مجانا
للشعب السوري سوريا دائما تقدم مساعدتك
محطات كهربيه
ولكن فعليا سوريا مسلوبه من الطاقه
الامريكيه جدا طيب روق روسيا استاذ دكتور
فيصل تملك 43% من موارد الارض فليس لها
حاجه
بينما خلينا نعود لما نلبس سؤال لازم تقدم
روسيا الى العالم بالعربي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع حلفاء
الاوروبيين يملكون فقط
92% هي لكل دول العالم كيف يعيش الغرب
وكيف يعيش الاخرين لان هذا يصرخ هذا امر
واضح ف السته سبعه مليار عايشين بالفقر
مليار الذهبي
روسي لازم تقدم الدول العربيه تقدم اول
شيء الامان الاقتصادي لهذه الدول لان تصبح
دول يعني تصبح الدول غير معنيه بي او غير
لا استقلاليه وسياده اقتصاديه يعني فعليا
ماذا تفعل امري
الطبيعيه العربيه هي فعاليا تعطيهم
دولارات وتطبع دولارات جديده يصبح على
سبيل المثال
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واوروبا طبعت
سبعه مليون دولار ويبرو بعد ازمه الكورونا
ما حصل انخفضه القيمه الشرائيه للدولار
بالنصف تقريبا وهذا ما قاله وزير الطاقه
السعوديه لما قالت واحد الصحفيات لماذا
تريد زياد اسعار النفقه لماذا لتر حليب
كان بدور اصبح بدورين لماذا يرتفع اسعار
النفط لانه لما بتصير التوازن اقتصادي
وبصيله دول في هناك عداله بالتقسيم
الثورات تستصحيح هذه الدول ان تاخذ
مكانتها وهذا ما قاله ولي العهد محمد بن
سلمان قال عندما استقل اقتصاديا سنصبح
اقوياء هذا امر مهم جدا اذا انت ضعيفا
واقتصادك معتمد على دوله اخرى ومعتمد على
ما يسمى الامبراطوريه الورقيه بنت الدولار
لا تستطيع ان تملك شيء بحاجه الى تغيير
جذري جميل جدا لذلك الدول هناك فرصه ثانيه
انه يقول ماذا قدمت روسيا تحاول يعني امر
بوندد تحاول ان تغير العالم وما حلفاء
الان هي الدول العربيه ودول العالم الاخر
الان ليست تحاول لتغيير الجذري لانه حتى
روسيا هي ضمن المنظومه اللي تسرقها لواجب
التحدي الامريكيه فروسيا هي يعني الان
ارجع اقول نحنا في الثوره على الهيمنه
الامريكيه وعلى استعمار الامريكي ففي حاجه
اما بالنسبه للاجئين امر مهم جدا للاجئين
اللاجئين هما عباره سرقه الموارد الشعبيه
السوريه الى دول اخرى اوروبا بحاجه الى
الشعب وامريكا بحاجه الى الشعوب في تسلق
الموارد روس ليست بحاجه لسرقه الموارد
سرقه البشر من من من فكر بالعبيد اول ما
يفكر بالعبيد هي الغرب وليست روسيا اول ما
استعمل العبيد الغرب ففعليا الى اوروبا
يتحولون الى عبيد بعد مده ليس لهم فهم
مامورين من هذه الدول
جميعا اخرى الارواح اخرى
الوقت ثائر يقول يقول يقول ان اوروبا يقول
ان يقول ان اوروبا همم تستعمر وتستعبط
رقاب العبيد او عق- رقاب البشر احيله الى
الكاتب الروسي العظيم الكاتب الروسي
العظيم نعم انا اقول نيكولاي جوجل عندما
كتب الارواح الميته التي تحدث عن النظام
الذي كان يستعبد ارواح ارواح ارواح الفلاح
الروسيه الحاكمه هؤلاء اثاره هؤلاء هم
الذين صنعوا ثوره الشعب الروسي لكن قبل ان
يستولوا عليها هؤلاء العسكر وهؤلاء
المارقين لذلك كله من يستعبد الشعوب روسيا
لديها تاريخ مخزي نقراه في الادب الروسي
من عظام الادباء الروس مثل نيكولاي جو
جوجل عندما فضح كيف انهم كيف كيف يبيعون
ارواح الموتى من الفقراء والفلاحين اوروبا
لديها تاريخ في التعامل مع ملف اللاجئين
روسيا التي يقول انها ليست بحاجه
لامكانيات مشاريع راينا بام العين كيف ان
روسيا او عزت
لذنب لوكيشنكو في بيلاروسيا عندما ذهب
بالاف اللاجئين الى الحدود البولنديه
وتركهم يموتون في العراء ولم يقدم لهم
شيئا نظام بلا روسيا وبولندا عندما اغلقت
الحدود حمايه الحدودها طلبت منهم روسيا ان
تدخل الى تامر الحدود هؤلاء كانوا عباره
عن ورقه روسيه تستقبل اللاجئين كوراقه
لاتزاز الغرب ثم ان اللاجئين السوريين
الذين عبروا روسيا وصولا الى فنلندا
ومعظمهم قتل من المافيا والميليشات يعني
اللاجيء الذي يدخل الاراضي الروسيه لا
يخرج منها الا ميتا حتى لا يتم احترامه
هناك اتفاقيه في الامم المتحده تقول وفقا
للمفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده اي لاجيء
يعبر حدود اي دوله تسقط عليه جريمه اعتداء
جريمه جريمه عبور الحدود باعتبار هيلاجه
اما روسيا تطبق هذه الاتفاقيه يعني روسيا
تتعامل مع العالم بانها خارج الامم
المتحده خارج قوانينها وين ويا رجل اللي
تم اعدامهم على الحدود الفلنديه السنه
الماضيه قتلى بالعشرات والربابه بالمئات
لكن الاعلام الروسي طبعا لا يستطيع ان
يسلط الضوء عليهم يعني لا يجيئون عبروا من
هنغاريا وصلوا الى اوروبا لا يجئون عبروا
من صربيا وصلوا الى اوروبا اللاجيء الذي
يمر عبر الاراضي الروسيه يفقد اثره لا
يوجد له اي اثر الذي يمر عبر الاراضي
البلا الروسيه يتم المساومه به ويتم
التعامل به كور ورقه وابتزاز للغرب هذه هي
روسيا التي تحترم حقوق الانسان هذه هي
روسيا التي تريد ان تبني العداله هذه
روسيا التي شعبها يامور ويريد ان ينظف
ويعبر نحن نثق بالشعب الروسي حقيقه وليست
لدينا مشكله مع الشعب الروسي فهو الشعب
عريق ولكن هذه النخبه وهذه الشرذمه ليست
شعارات هذه حقيقه لكن هذه النقطه
وبالمناسبه روسي اقرب لنا نحن المشرقين من
غرب نعم انا اعتذر بذلك لكن روسيا الشعب
وليس روسيا هذه الطغمه او هذا النظام
الحاكم الذي صار له من 100 عام من 1917
وحتى اليوم لا يزال هذا النظام يعيد انتاج
نفسه باشكال وباليات جديده روسيا اليوم لا
تستطيع ان تقدم شيئا للعرب لانها حقيقه لم
تقدم شيئا لجمهوريات اسيا الوسطى سود الذل
والفقر والماء والمهانه ولذلك كله اذا ما
قارن بين روسيا وما قد ثمنه كم عدد
المثقفين العرب الذين يتكلمون اللغه
الروسيه مقارنه بالذين يتكلمون للانجليزيه
كم عدد المبتعثين العرب الى روسيا مقارنه
بالعربي الذين يبتعثون الى اوروبا والى
امريكا سنجد الفارق الكبير ان العرب
روحانيه اقرب الى الغرب وثقافه الغرب
لانها الثقافه التي تعتبر هي السند وهي
التي تعتبر طريق التطور وليست الثقافه
الروسيه او الثقافه هذه التي تنتجها
النخبه الحاكمه في روسيا اليوم لذلك كله
لا مقارنه مطلقه ولا ريهان للعرب ان
يذهبوا بالتجاه روسيا ربما هناك على قات
لكن هذه العلاقات لا ترقى مطلقه لان تكون
علاقه ثم ان روسيا لا تحترم حلفاءها
مطلقان عمران خان رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
السابق عندما تقرب من روسيا سقط لم تستطع
روسيا ان تحميه مطلقا مقارنه بالبلدان
العربيه التي تمتلك علاقات تحالفيه مع
الولايات احد الامريكيه لكن الولايات
المتحده واوروبا على الاقل تحترم حلفائها
عندما طبعت الدول العربيه بلدان الخليج مع
اسرائيل قطر الدوله الوحيده التي لم تطبع
قطر خليفه لامريكا لكن امريكا لم تضغط على
قطر وتقول لها طبعي مع اسرائيل عندما
حاصرت بلدان الخليج قطر قبل خمس سنوات لم
تتدخل امريكا لتقول لحلفائها فك الحصار عن
قطر بمعنى ان امريكا تحترم على الاقل حد
ادنى من العلاقه ما حلفائها بخلاف روسيا
اعطني رئيس اليوم في كازاخستان يستطيع ان
يقول لا لبوتين مطلقه لا يستطيع ان يقول
له ذلك راينا كيف جرت الحرف في ارمينيا
وهذا يعني كيف ان روسيا تلاعبت على
الطرفين وكيف انها كسبت هذه الحرب لصالحها
مقارنه بمناطق اخرى يعني روسيا لا افاده
حصل ولا الشعوب البلقانيه اللهم سواء
امراء الحرب زاد ثروتهم ولم يستطيع الشعب
في البلقان وفي القوقاز ولا حتى في الشرق
الاوسط يعني من يريد ان يراهن على روسيا
عليها ان ينظر ماذا جرى في البلقان وعليه
ان يرى ماذا جرى في القوقاز لهذه الشعوب
في الشيشان في البوسنه حتى في صربيا حتى
في مونتاجروا ومقدونيا شعوب حتى اليوم
تعيش الفقر وتعيش حاله النداء اللي انعدام
الاقتصادي الكامل وهي تتطلع وتتحاول
التطلع ليه الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
هذا هو الواقع حقيقه اليوم روسيا اليوم لا
تستطيع حقيقه ان تجابه اتحاد الكره
فيصل اخر جمله اخر جمله
لكان الروسي اليوم لكان الروسي اليوم
اللمونا اللغه الالمانيه منذ عام 1940
تمام لولا الغرب ولولا السلاح الغربي
ولولا انجال النورماندي ولولا لولايه تحت
الامريكيه والغرب باكمله لكانت اليوم
لكانت اليوم روسيا تتكلم الالمانيه كما
كانت تتكلما في عهد من روسيا جميل جدا
محمود افندي محمود الافندي طيب العرب انتم
يعني المدافعون او المدافعين عن الخط
الروسي دائما دائما تقولون يا اخي انظر
ماذا فعلت امريكا امريكا احتلت ودمرت
العراق امريكا احتلت ودمرت افغانستان
امريكا فعلت امريكا كذا طيب بالاتجاه
الاخر من الذي غزا افغانستان في 1979
وقتل وقتل وشرد بالمناسبه همم روسيا او
الاتحاد السوفيتي قتل من الافغان مليون
و200,000 افغاني ما حدا بيسمعوا عنا
شرد خمسه ملايين لاجئ افغاني بالسبعينات
باخر السبعينات طيب
العراق ماشي
اسمه العراق
دلني على بلد ماذا فعلت بالشيشان ماذا
فعلت بجورجيا ماذا فعلت بالقرم ماشي حتى
ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي كل البلدان التي
كانت منضويه تحت لواء الاتحاد السوفيتي
كانت بلدانا محتله للروسي الروس كانوا
يحتلونها فبماذا تبشر العرب يا دكتور
افندي يعني يروحوا مع روسيا ما يعني زعلته
طيب اول شيء بدي اعقب على كلام الاستاذ
ثائر اول الشيخ لما بيحكي على الاقطاعيه
الروسيه كان الاقطاعيه في كل الدول العالم
في كل دول العالم فليش عم بحكي عروس
بالذات يعني كل الدول العالم
ليس له علاقه في اي موضوع هذا اول شيء
ثاني شيء اخطاء خطا تاريخي اذا بتتكلم عن
الانسان الفرق عام 1945 حرب العالميه
الثانيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم
تشارك فعليا الحرب العالميه الثانيه هي
شاركت فقط لما روسيا وصلت الى برلين طيب
وقتها قتلت على فكره دمرت مدينتين
باليابان
محمود دكتور دكتور
محمود كيف تفسر كيف تفسر ان مثلا الكثير
من الفلسطينيين كيف تفكر ان الكثير من
الفلسطينيين يؤيدون روسيا يؤيدون روسيا
ويؤيدون الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا مع انه مهم تحت الاحتلال
لاسرائيلي هل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حرام
والاحتلال الروسي حلال كيف تبررها ان سؤال
جيد ايه تفضل
سؤال سؤال جيد جدا ورائع وعلى فكره بدي
اصاله
لان الشعب الفلسطيني يعلم سياسي اكثر
بكثير من بعض اطول فيه شو طريقه لما بتحصل
الشعب الفلسطيني يعلم جيد عند وجود دوله
اسرائيل وحمايته فقط من الدول الغربيه هي
من تحمي اسرائيل وهي مسؤوله عن امن
اسرائيل روسيا هي ليست حالي في اسرائيل
بينما الغرف فعليا واضعاف العرب يعني
فعليا لماذا تستطيع فلسطين ان تاخذ همم
تستعيد اراضيها لان الدول العربيه مهيمن
عليها القرار امريكي في كل الدول العربيه
كل الدول العربيه اتحد قناه امريكيه
فعندما الدول العربيه تقدم لهم روسي
السياده يستطيعون ان يتحدوا ويصبعوه قوه
اقتصاديه كبيره ويستضعوه
هل تريد
تتدخل هل تريد ان تقول لي ان روسيا تعمل
لصالح الشعب الفلسطيني والعربي لذلك يقفون
معها فلسطين روسيا وف فلسطين
طبعا فلسطين بالذات لانه فلسطين تحصل على
استقلال فقط عن طريق الوحده العربيه فقط
لا تستطيع لان ضعيفه جدا وموجوده تحت حصار
محاصره ومحاصره للاسف في بعض بعد الدول
العربيه همم علاقتها مع اسرائيل ففعليا لا
تستطيع الا اذا توحد العرب توحد العرب
ستخرج اسرائيل لما تكون دوله محاوله في
الاعداء لا تستطيع ان تعيش كدولكونه
يا دكتور محمود يا دكتور محمود انا والله
بدي بوصلك من شان تروح بس انت عم تبعد
كثير السؤال المطروح يعني روسيا من حق
العرب ان يراهن وعلى روسيا لانها مع
قضاياهم وتدعم قضاياهم مش هذا هو قصدك
وتدعم القضيه الفلسطينيه بس انا بدي اسالك
اذا هيك دكتور محمود هل تعلم
هل تعلم هل تعلم ان معظم الطيارين
الاسرائيليين هل تعرف ان الطيارين
الاسرائيليين الذين يدمرون غزه ويقتناها
الفلسطينيين كلهم من اصول روسيه او الكثير
منهم الروسيه يعني كيف بدي صدقت بعدين من
هو اكبر لوبي من روسيا من هم اكبر لوبي ما
هو اكبر لوبي في في اسرائيل هو اللوبي
الروسي من يحكم من يحكم الكثير في اسرائيل
هم الروس هل اليهود الروس وجاي يدخل
لفلسطين ومقاومه ومقاوم جي ومنعجي ومماتعه
ومقاومه وما بعرف شو كيف ترد شوف
طبعا انت عم تحكي كلام ولكن
كانت اوكرانيه شارون كان اوكراني في امر
مهم جدا موجودين الاوكرانيين اصلا كان هي
جنه اليهود هي كانت اوكرانيا وليست روسيا
هون اتحاد السوفيتي بقول لك اه ولكن روسيا
لا هي بي اوكرانيا يعني حتى الرئيس كده
يهودي وهو اكبر فاشل في الموضوع الشعب
الاوكراني ففعليا
انا باتكلم عن الطيارين ليسوا الروس
ولكن هناك يهود مقيمين في روسيا
فعليا فعليا
يا دكتور اوكرانيا اوديسا هي عباره عن
اغلبيه اليهود
كل المدن الروسيه اغلبيه اليهود موجودين
كان في اوكرانيا
بالنسبه له فلسطين واسرائيل في امر مهم
جدا في امر جدا يجب ان يعني ان يعطيك شوف
في
الفلسطينيين يعلمون جيدا ان فعليا اذا
استطاعت روسيا ان تدعم الروح العربيه او
تدعى بالمقاومه
الان في كل الدول العربيه الوحيده التي
تحافظ على الحقوق وهذا ما كان الرئيس عباس
لما كان بسبب مع الرئيس بوتين قال لا نريد
حاله من امريكا نريد حلم الروسيا هذا امر
مهم جدا لانه الحلول غير عادي
كل الدول هي بتاعه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الاستعلام السياسه الاستعماريه
باستغلال الموارد واستغلال الشعوب هذا
الامر اذا حصلت عليه يمكن ان تتقدم الى
الامام ولكن ان نعامل ان نحل الامر بشكل
هذا الامر الامر جزء حي من العمق العمق
الجزري اخراج الهيمنه من المنطقه يمكن ان
تستطيع الدول العربيه ان تتكلم على سبيل
المثال الدول العربيه لها لغه واحده
تستطيع بسهوله
خلينا بس نقطه مهمه ثائر الناشف هل تستطيع
ان تنكر بان الان التوجه العربي على
الصعيد الفلسطيني والمقاومه باتجاه روسيا
شاهدنا قبل فتره بعض قاده المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في روسيا والعلاقات بدات تاخذ
شكلا افضل بكثير همم قال لك قبل قليل ليس
صحيحا ليس صحيحا ان ان الطيارين الذين
يقصفون غزه هم من الروس وان الذين يحكمون
اسرائيل هم من الروس والى ما هنالك من هذا
الكلام في هذه ال- ال- الجزئيه يا ريت
تدخل فيها
يا دكتور فيصل بوتين هو من اعلن ذلك على
لسانه صراحه قبل خمس سنوات زار كالابيب
والتقى صديقه بنيامين نتنياهو ان تتعلم
غرفه العمليات المشتركه الروسيه
الاسرائيليه التي يعني دمرت سوريا والتي
كانت تستخدم الغارات تصور انهم يقصفون
مناطق النظام وبعض المناطق الاخرى روسيا
لا تتدخل لتحميه ذنبها في سوريا بسبب هذا
التنسيق الامن والعسكري الاسرائيلي الروسي
الذي يضع غرفه عمليات مشتركه
الاحتفالات قالها بلسانه
الروسيه ان الثقافه الاسرائيليه ان
الثقافه الاسرائيليه
وان الاغاني التي يسمعها الشعب الاسرائيلي
هي اغاني روسيه وان ثلاثه ارباع الشعب
الاسرائيلي هم يهود روسيا نعم هناك يهود
في اوكرانيا كما هو هناك يهود في بولندا
وهؤلاء
ولكن اليهود الروس لديهم الثقل الاكبر
12% من اثرياء روسيا الثروه تتحكم بيد
الاشكناز الموجودين حتى اليوم في روسيا
اصحاب القرار الاقتصادي والقرار الاعلامي
اكبر محللين السياسيين والاستراتيجيين في
الاعلام الروسي وفي القنوات الروسيه شخصيه
يهوديه روسيه لا تنكر ذلك هذه وقائع
وبوتين بنفسه واعلن بذله بوتين نفسه ذهب
رسول الله
اما بالنسبه تفضل نعم يعني هذه المساله
واضحه لا تعيب روسيا ولا تعيب بيوتين
عندما يتقرب الى اليهود ثم انه لا تذكر
دكتور فيصل كيف ان بنيامين نتنياهو وزوجته
ساره كيف انهم استقبلوا بوتين بطريقه مذله
عندما ضل بوتين جالسا على الكرسي ودخل اا
ظل نتنياهو جالسا على الكرسي ودخل بروتين
فسلم بوتين على نتنياهو دون ان يتزحزح
بوتين ودون ان يقف
يعني
كيف بشار الاسد
موجود عندكم تستطيعون في الجزيره انتظروا
هذا المقطع هذا المقطع منتشر يعني
يعني الدليل
دليل على ان روسيا تتشدق يعني تقول تقول
لي تقول لي ان ان روسيا ليس لها شان
باليوم وليس لها علاقه باليا
محمود
يا محمود محمود
الروس
يعقوب سفير دلوف مؤسس الحزب الشيوعي مع
اليمين
روسي هذا كان الرجل كان رقم واحد في الحزب
الشيوعي في عام 1917 يهودي روسي بعمر 30
سنه هذا هؤلاء دروس
المانيا
ولكن هناك ايضا يهود رؤوس كان لهم اليد
الطول في تاسيس الاتحاد السوفيتي وفي دعم
دوله اسرائيل وفي تاسيس
اكثر من ما فعلت بريطانيا واكثر مما فعلت
فرنسا ايضا في دعم هذه حقيقه يعني بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين دكتور بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
الذين يراهنون ويعولون على على روسيا
ساقول لهم انتم تايدون احتلال روسيا
لاوكرانيا لكن بالمقابل اليست هذه
ازدواجيه معايير تتهمون الغرب انه يكيل
بمكيالين اليس ازواجهات معايير غدا تطالب
اسرائيل بان تكون القدس عاصمه الدوله
اليهوديه ماذا يمكن بهؤلاء الفلسطينيين ان
يقولوا طالب انك تؤيد احتلال دوله اخرى
بالتالي اسرائيل تمتلك الحجه والذريه
القانونيه بان تصرح ان القدس عاصمه ابديه
وعاصمه للدوله اليهوديه طالما انك تقيل
بمكيالين وتتبع هذه المعايير المزدوجه
فاسرائيل غدا ستقول انني ساضم الضفه
الغربيه وليس لك اي حق بمناسبه اسرائيل او
بمحاجه اسرائيل المساله تحتاج قليل من
الوعي قليل من الانضباط قليل من عقلانيه
ايضا على بالا بالنسبه لما يتعلق
بالقيادات الفلسطينيه وبالشارع وبالصفه
الفلسطيني ثم انه الدكتور فيصل اعطيني
مبادره روسيه واحده للسلام جميع مبادرات
السلام الاسرائيليه الفلسطينيه كلها كانت
بترتيب اوروبي امريكي
مبادره واحده للسلام العربي الاسرائيلي لن
تقدم اي مبادره لا تستطيع ان تقوم بدور
سلام ولا تستطيع ان تقوم بدور تطبيع ولا
تستطيع ان ترعى اتفاقيه سلام لان اتفاقيه
السلام تحتاج الى ترتيبات عديده اقتصاديه
وغير ذلك وروسيا لا تملك يعني حقيقه ما
تقدمه حتى للشعب الروسي المغلوب على امره
الذي اليوم يعاني ازمه جدا بسبب هذه الحرب
الاوجاع على اوكرانيا وبسبب التدهور
الكبير الذي اصاب الاقتصاد الروسي خاصه ان
الصين تنظر الى اوروبا الى امريكا الصين
تبادلاتها التجاريه مع الغرب همم
يا جماعه
دكتور دقيقه بس تاريخيا من شان يوضح تفضل
انت تعلم من هي اول دوله في التاريخ
اعترفت باسرائيل روسيا انت تعلم ان اتفاق
سايكس بيكو الذي قسم العرب لم يكن اتفاق
سايكس بيكو اه كان اتفاق سايكس بيكو
ساذانوف الروسي الروس كانوا مشاركين بس
طلعوا من اللعب بعدين كيف ترد
بتعطيني وقت الكافي
في واحد يهودي اعطيني اسمه
بالنسبه للاتحاد السوفيتي بالفعل هي اول
دوله اعترفت باسرائيل هذا كلام صحيح ولكن
احنا عم نقلط الاوراق بين روسيا والاتحاد
السوفيتي الاتحاد السوفيتي غير روسيا الان
الاتحاد السوفيتي كان دوله اشتراكيه
الشيوعيه الان روسيا الدوله الراسماليه
علمانيه هذا عمر مهم جدا فالخلط بين
الاتحاد السوفيتي والروسي الى خطا كبير
هذا امر مهم جدا واتفاقيه السائق اسمه كان
مع الامبراطوريه الروسيه وليست مع كذا ومع
ذلك في سؤال مهم مشاهدين لما ذهب سفير
الاتحاد السوفيتي واعطى موسيقى الى ال همم
الرئيس وقطيع العربي كان همم
شريف حسين اعطاه لم يصدقه ففعليا همم تم
سايكس بيكو ولكن فعليا
نعود الى ابو الروسيا روسيا ليست مسؤوله
عن الاتحاد السوفيتي وعلاقتها علاقتها مع
اسرائيل تتكلم الاخ سائر ان روسيا الى
علاقات مع اسرائيل روسياسه على قد مع
اسرائيل روسيا تحاول ان تريد ان ترحل بين
القضيه الفلسطينيه ووجود اسرائيل حتى
يعيشون بسلام ولكن فعليا هذا لم يحصل لان
اسرائيل هي دائما دوله عدوانيه مدعومه
غربيه وليست روسيا وصيه سائل لما قال عدم
احترامه لابوت او عدم التهاب الروبوت هذا
دليل روسيا اسرائيل وروسيا ما بتنسخ مع
اسر اي من ضربات الجويه على سوريا حتى
اسرائيل بتبلغ روسي قبل ثانيتين فقط من
ضربات جويه
جدا جدا
بس بس دكتور محمود
عندنا وقت كثير باختصار شديد للضيفين همم
ثائر
روسيا بانها تقف مع الطغاهات وتقف مع
الديكتاتوريه
بس بس دقيقه
روح لا يا ثائر هل هناك طاغيه عربي واحد
او طاغيه من بلدان العالم الثالث لم تصنعه
امريكا بكل الطغاه الذين الذين برزوا
عربيا وغير عربيا ورائهم امريكا بمن فيهم
بشار الاسد حتى الروس قالوا لو ارادت
امريكا اسقاط بشار لم استطعنا ان نفعل له
شيئا لا ما استطعنا ان نفعل له شيئا ماشي
هذا من جهه من جهه ثاني يعني كيف ترد على
على هذا على هذا النفاق الامريكي بجمله
واحده
يعني يا دكتور فيصل دائما هناك خيار بين
المر والامر يعني اذا كان لديك المرور فلا
تذهب الى الامر يعني نعم نعم
روسيا بحرق سوريا وبتدمير سوريا
قالوا الضوء الاخضر اخذته روسيا من الغرب
امريكا التي اندرو اتسون مساعد لوزير
الدفاع الامريكي قال نحن الذين اطلقنا
يدرس روسيا لتذبح سوريا ورئيس الوزراء
اليوناني قال نفس الشيء رئيس الوزراء
الفرنسي الاسبق قال نفس الشيء نحن الذين
تركنا» تضع اللوم على روسيا ولا تضع اللوم
على الغرب اللي بتدافع عنه وهو الذي سلط
علينا روسيا وخلت سوري روسيا تذبح
السوريين وتذبح ليبيين وتذبح وتذبح بجمله
واحده
لان هناك اتفاق حقيقه نعم جرى اتفاق بين
الغرب والولا تحت الامريكيه وروسيا وهذا
الامر لا يقبل احد اتفاق لابروفي كيري جون
كيري وزير الخارجيه الامريكي السابق ولكن
عندما كان هذا الاتفاق بين روسيا والتحدي
الامريكيه روسيا استلمت الشعب السوري كانه
شاه وقامت بذبحها علنا هذا هو الذي جرى
اليوم عندما روسيا استفدت بالشعب السوري
لا نذكر ذلك
ماذا تقول للعرب الذين يسكنون في لندن
وباريس
وفرانكفورت وكل الدول الاوروبيه ويتمنون
النصر لروسيا على على اوروبا على الغرب
بجمله واحده بدي اروح لمحمود
اقول لهم الصلعاء تتباهى بشعر بنت خالتها
واللي اختشوا ماتوا لكن هؤلاء لا يختشون
ولا يستحون اذا انهم يعيشون في الغرب منذ
عشرات السنين ويتنعمون بقوانين الغرب
وبنوا حياتهم واسسوا حياتهم على اساس
قوانين الغرب واليوم يراهنون على روسيا
لماذا لا يذهبون الى روسيا لماذا لا
يذهبون للعيش في روسيا
ويتشدقون بروسيا ربما
ذلك محمود الافندي ماذا تقول للعرب في
نهايه البرنامج بخصوص مستقبل روسيا
والعلاقات مع روسيا الكلمه الاخيره لك
شوف انا بقول لك كمان انا وصلت نقطه مهمه
اول حلقه بالنسبه للاجتماعي العربي
يحافظون على ثقافتهم لا يريد نقل الثقافي
يعني نرى جيدا ما حصل في قطر من حوالي
اسبوع
العرب العرب
يجب ان يحافظ على ثقافتهم وحضارتهم والحل
الوحيد هو ان يدعم روسيا ويظلوا يدعم
روسيا للتخلص
الغربيه لا تلائنا نحن لسنا المصريين وليس
من وليس مش عايزين جنسيين هم يريد ادخال
هذه الثقافه الى الاراضي العربيه
المقبل فحتى ذلك الحين وفيصل القاسم
نحييكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]